hello everybody and welcome to another
technique class at home I hope you are
all doing fine today we will work on our
posture because the posture is the very
first thing you should Target when you
want to improve your tunnel from the
ground up yeah a good posture allows for
good balance and good balance is the
basis of everything else you need to do
in Tango yeah so posture means you're
back yeah from the hip to your head your
spine yeah the spine is what holds your
torso straight yeah so when you want to
improve your posture you use exercises
that Target your back that's how you do
it yeah now the people who have been
following this channel for a while they
will be already familiar with the
exercises that we will do but these
exercises were scattered in different
videos so I put them all together in
this video in a routine that is very
effective yeah and that I use my myself
very often contained so I hope you will
like it and let's start with the one
okay one more so let's put our feet
together straight posture look in front
of you and relax the arms and we start
with shoulder rotations shoulder circles
yeah so remember we do the big and slow
we keep the arms relaxed we don't bend
the elbows like this and we do them from
the front to the back okay let's do
eight
one
to
three
four
five
six
seven
eight now we do arm circles remember we
leave both arms at the same time we keep
the elbows straight the shoulders down
when you when the hands are up and then
we open the arms and when you pass them
by this position the hands are slightly
behind your back so that you open your
chest properly okay and then we start
again we do eight yeah slow and big
one
two
three
four
five
open the chest
six
keep the elbow straight
seven
and eight okay now we do torso balance
to each side so we start by lifting one
arm make sure the elbow is straight and
the hands pointing up and keep the other
hand on your leg then slide the hand
down the leg until you can touch your
knee
and you stretch the side of the Torso so
hold the stretch a little bit and then
use the hand that is up to pull yourself
up again into the vertical and then
repeat to the other side okay so we do
it four times to each side alternating
side let's go
one
go down touch the knee hold the stretch
and go up there
one lift the arm go down the leg touch
the knee
hold the stretch
and block
two
go down
that's the knee hold it
and water
to
pull down the leg that's the knee hold
it
and go back
three
go down the knee
hold it
go up
three or how many
all the stretch
go up
four
slide down that's the knee hold it
go up
and four go down the leg press the knee
hold the stretch
and up
okay now we do rotations for the middle
so open the legs keep the knees straight
and the heels on the floor yeah and make
a circle with your arms at the level of
the chest below the chest okay and then
rotate your torso left and right without
rotating the hip and without rotating
the head hip and head always look
forward okay and we do it twice eight
times to each side okay let's go
one two
three
four and five and six and seven and
eight eight more one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay now from this position put your
hands behind your head like this
and bend the Torso forward I'll show you
from your profile
like this then first bend the Torso
forward slowly until your back is
parallel to the floor and then keep
going down until your back goes down and
your head is hanging yeah and then
bounce three times one two three and
then from here start with the head
look forward and go up to the initial
position okay when you are down here
don't go up from the lower back like
this
it's not wrong if you do it but it's a
little bit harder when you're here use
the hair to look forward and it's much
easier to come up okay so let's do it
this way
so let's do it eight times okay let's do
it together
and go down one
then bounce bounce bounce look forward
and walk
bounce
and water
three go down slowly take your time
bounce bounce bounce and go up slowly
four go down
bounce bounce bounce
and go up there
five
go down
bounce bounce bounce and water keep your
legs straight all the time yeah keep
your knees straight six go down
bounce bounce bounce
and walk
seven go down keep your knee straight
bounce bounce bounce
and water
and eight go down
bounce bounce bounce
and water okay now keep the legs open
and the knees straight and heels on the
floor during the whole exercise and grab
your hips and now move your feet back as
if you wanted to touch the wall behind
you with your bum and then move your hip
to the side yeah keeping your legs
straight then forward then the side and
then back in a Wide Circle we will do it
eight times to one side and eight times
in the direction okay so let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
and now the other character one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay now you can put your feet together
again for the next exercise keep your
hands on your hips if you want straight
posture and look forward and it is to
bend your knees unbox three times one
two three then stretch the knees go
slightly forward so you can lift your
heels and then go up and support
yourself on the ball of the foot yeah
when you are here make sure that your
legs and feet don't open like this yeah
keep them closed together as much as you
can and then go down slowly don't go
down fast yeah slowly and controlled and
then you repeat go down and about three
times okay let's do it eight times
so go down one bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold this position
and go down slowly two bounce bounce
bounce
go up hold it
and go down three bounce bounce bounce
go down four bounce bounce bounce go up
quality
go down five dollars bounce bounce
go up keep your feet together
go down six bounce bounce bounce
go up on the ball of the foot hold it
slow down seven bounce bounce bounce
go up
go down on the last one bounce bounce
bounce
go up push the floor hold it
and go down and the last one we stretch
the calf muscles so I'll show you from
the profile
you just make a big step back
and make sure that the heel is on the
floor the knee is straight and the foot
is pointing forward don't open the foot
like this because then you won't be
stretching the calf muscles properly you
will be stretching only the inside yeah
so put the foot pointing forward point
the foot forward so that you make sure
that you are stretching the calf muscle
symmetrically properly okay and then
bend the forward leg until you feel a
good stretch behind you have keep the
leg straight if you have problems with
balance you can support yourself on a
wall or a chair or something but try to
be able to do it with your own balance
okay and now let's hold this position 20
seconds so bend the knee forward
make sure the back foot is pointing
forward and holding one
two
three
four five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten ten seconds more one
two
three
four
five
six
seven eight nine ten now stretch the
front knee slowly so that you get out of
the position in a controlled way and
let's be to the other side so big step
back
make sure the heel is on the floor yeah
the knee is straight and the back foot
is pointing forward yeah not open
forward and now bend the front leg until
you feel a good stretch
and hold it 20 seconds one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten ten more one
two
three four
five
six seven
hey
nine
ten now stretch the front knee get out
of the position and relax the legs and
we're ready we can go to the first
exercise
okay for the first exercise we will use
a wall I'm going to do is with your back
to the wall you put your hip on the wall
like this yeah your feet are a little
bit apart same distance as your
shoulders they are also a bit apart from
the wall and your knees are bent yeah
your legs are relaxed and the first
thing you do is you put your whole back
including the back of your head on the
wall now breathe deeply
so that your belly goes inside
and you make sure that you are pressing
the wall with your whole back yeah and
here starts the exercise and first you
lower your head
as if you want to bring your chin as
close as possible to your chest yeah
then from here you continue rolling your
back down like this vertebrate them now
until your lower back
and then you continue until the only
thing touching the wall is the hip yeah
and from here you rewind the movement
you roll your back slowly vertebra by
vertical
up
so that your back straightens yeah and
at the last you raise your head it
touches the wall and that's the start
position and then you repeat okay now a
few things that you have to take care
with in this exercise
are when you start don't take shortcuts
yeah then remove your butt from the wall
all at the same time you have to start
with the head and then you have to
continue vertical by vertical when you
go down
make this Arc with your torso as tight
as possible yeah as tight as possible
really round and compact yeah when you
are here be careful that your hip
doesn't move don't do this yeah your
hips should not move throughout the
whole exercise it should stay like this
without moving yeah then when you are
here also don't take shortcuts don't put
your back again up all at the same time
you have to put one vertebra at a time
from the lower back to the upper back
yeah
place
that's the exercise okay
so let's do it eight times slowly yeah
and the reason why we do this very slow
is that you have to make sure that you
go through each vertebrae without
skipping any yeah you have to go through
each part of your back one by one that's
why it takes time okay so let's start
this exercise should be very relaxing as
well
put your butt on the wall breathe deeply
and then we start with the first one
going ahead one
roll it down slowly
until
your hip
here
and then roll up
slowly
until the head
two
start with a head
and roll down slowly
so until your hip
and two or up
slowly
under your head three
roll down
slowly
until your hip
and all that
slowly vertically vertical and inhale
four from down
slowly you can close your eyes if it
helps you to feel your back better
yeah roll down until the hip
and then roll up slowly very difficult
until the head five
or down
slowly
until your hip
roll up
slowly until your head
six
go down
slowly
contain your hip
and roll up
slowly counting the hair
seven
roll down
America
until your hip
and roll up
slowly into your head
and eight
roll down
slowly
until your hip
I don't know
slowly until your head
okay let's go to the second exercise
okay the second exercise starts in the
same position as the first yeah with
your whole back on the back of your head
on the wall yeah so you breathe deeply
and you press your whole back on the
wall yeah then we will do the opposite
of what we did before so we will roll
our back away from the wall starting
from the hip yeah so the first movement
is to Tilt The Hip forward like this
so that you remove it from the wall yeah
only the Heap and then from here you
continue rolling your back up
so that it goes a wealth away from the
wall until the only thing touching the
wall is your your upper back like this
yeah and then here you rewind so you put
your back down on the wall again you
roll it down until the last thing is
your hip like this yeah so the first
part is you Tilt The Hip forward and
then you roll up
and then you roll down from your upper
back
until the last thing is the hip okay now
here the same things apply don't take
shortcuts don't remove your butt from
the wall all at the same time like this
you have to start only with the hip yeah
with this movement and then continue and
when you are here also don't move your
back on the wall all at the same time
like this you have to pull it on the
wall slowly vertebrate
from the upper back to the hip okay
okay so let's do it eight times slowly
so that we make sure that we don't skip
any Vector up
and start one
start with the hip
roll up
until the upper back and then roll down
slowly
until you make it
two
take the hip away roll up slowly until
the upper back
and then roll your back down
until your hip
nice three
roll your back up
until the upper back
and roll it down
onto your machine
four
roll it up
under here
and then roll it down slowly learn to
relax until your feet five take your hip
away from the wall and roll the back up
and roll down
and then until
six
roll up slowly
and roll down
yeah keep your head on the wall all the
time
seven
roll up
slowly
and roll down
until the hip
and eight
start with a hip roll up vertical
until your upper back and then roll down
from the upper back
until your hip
okay good let's go to the next exercise
okay for this exercise you will need a
stick and what you do is with your feet
a little bit apart you wrap the stick
with a white bead like this yeah and you
hold it in front of you with your arms
extended and then you leave the stick
until it passes above your head and then
continue until it passes behind your
back until it touches your hip okay
that's that and then you rewind the
movement you pass your stick behind your
back above the head in front of your
chest and then down to your front to
your hip yeah so one Circle going back
like this until the hip and then one
Circle going forward until the front of
your hip and that's one repetition okay
now this exercise will help you a lot
with the placement of your shoulder yeah
it will correct the tendency of the
shoulder to go forward like this yeah
because this rotation of the shoulder
yeah it opens the chest it stretches the
spark and it forces the shoulder to be
on the center okay
now things you have to take into account
when doing this exercise is that the
wider you grab the stick the easier the
exercise is especially this part when
you pass it behind your back yeah if the
grip is wide this is easy so I recommend
that you start with a white lid yeah so
that you get used to the exercise and
then when it feels easy then you can
grab the stick a little bit more narrow
yeah with a narrower meat and then this
part when you pass the stick behind your
back will be more challenging yeah you
will feel uh
a bigger stretch of the chest yeah
another thing you need to be careful
with is that your shoulder your elbows
are straight all the time yeah don't
bend the elbows because then it will be
impossible to pass the stick behind your
back or very very difficult yeah if you
do this uh your shoulder won't work
right it would be a bit painful yeah so
you should always have your arms
completely straight yeah then this part
is possible okay elbow strength
yeah so let's do it eight times together
hold the stick in front of you
and look at the front so that your head
is straight and let's go one
go back
and your front two
go back and go front
three
go back
go front
four
go back
go front
five
go back
go from
six go back
seven
go back
go front and
and go for it okay now if you feel your
chest stretched and open you can then
try to repeat it grabbing the stick a
little bit narrower okay
okay for the last exercise we will use
the wall again and these exercises will
improve your posture especially when you
are dancing in clothes and brakes yeah
and the exercise works like this you're
facing the wall now you put your feet
together and you find a distance with
the wall that is similar to the wrist
that you will have with somebody you are
going to dance in close Embrace with
yeah so I recommend between your foot
and the world more or less more than the
width of a food yeah like this
then you close your fingers
and then you place your hands above your
head yeah you stretch the elbows and you
point towards the ceiling with the palms
of your hand yeah the Palms pointing to
the same now imagine that you could
touch the same with your hands and you
want to push it up yeah push push push
push this will stretch the nose and also
it will lift your rib cage yeah your
ribs will move up away from the hip yeah
this will already improve the posture
yeah like this then the exercise starts
and what you do is
you move forward until you make contact
with the world like this
and then you go back to your axis yeah
you go forward touch the wall
and then back to the axis
now a few things that you have to take
into account so that you do the exercise
correctly the first thing don't forget
about the arms yeah don't let the elbows
Bend slowly keep your arms straight all
the time all the time pushing up yeah
all the time
the second thing when you go forward
don't touch the wall with the chest yeah
because if you touch the wall with a
chest this will happen that you won't
have any space for your head yeah you
have to touch the wall with the ribs
below the chest here at this point yeah
the middle of your torso yeah work works
hard the ribs the ribs go to the wall
yeah like this ribs
okay
the next thing is when you are towards
the wall don't land hard yeah for
example if you are too far away from the
wall like this
you will learn Glory like this
boom yeah and you don't want to do this
because this is not what you will do
with a partner yeah with a partner you
would land in a very controlled way yeah
you will make contact very soft and very
controlled so adjust your distance yeah
don't be so close that the exercise is
very easy yeah but also don't be so far
that you fall on the wall yeah
find the distance that works for you
there is a little bit challenging okay
the next thing is don't go back to the
axis by using a rebound yeah don't
believe rebound and then to the axis
rebound because then coming back to the
axis is very easy you're using the
rebound so what you have to do is go
forward and when you touch the wall wait
one second here just wait one second and
then from here you go back to the axis
yeah go back to the axis without
momentum from zero and how do you do
that exactly
when you're here
you push the floor with the front of
your feet yeah the toes and the ball one
you push down on the floor yeah because
the foot works as a lever like however
so when you push down yeah the foot will
push you also back to your axis yeah so
you are here
and then you push down on the floor
and this will bring you back to the axis
also in a very controlled way okay so
when you go to the wall when you come
back that's one repetition
so let's do it eight times together okay
fit together straight poster find the
distance
cross the fingers hands up now push the
ceiling push push push fill your ribs
going up and then we start eight times
one go forward touch the wall wait one
second
and then go to the axis
two go forward
that's the one
and go back
three
go forward that's the wall
and work
four forward
with the ribs
and go back to the axis
five
that's the wall
push the floor go back
six or four touch the wall
go back
seven
forward that's the one
back to the axis
and eight
that's the one wait a second
and back to the axis slowly
okay
good
this exercise will improve your posture
a lot and will improve also how you
embrace your apartment and close your
brace yeah so that's the series of
exercises and now I would recommend you
that you repeat the whole routine at
least twice more okay so that was the
class I hope you liked it and I want to
say thank you to the people who support
this Channel with donations or those who
Book Online private classes with me if
you would like to do those things the
links are down below in the description
of the video okay so thank you once
again and I will see you on the next
video bye